I've spent the last 15 years pretty
obsessed by a single question which is
what is it that holds capable driven
people from breaking through to the next
level and the answer to that question to
my great surprise is success I first
observed this working with executive
teams in Silicon Valley where I noticed
that when they were focused on a few
things it led to success but success
breeds so many opportunities and options
that that defuse the very focus that led
to success in the first place and so
exaggerating the point in order to make
it
I found that success becomes a catalyst
for failure because it leads to what jim
collins called the undisciplined pursuit
of more the antidote to that problem is
the disciplined pursuit of less but
better that means exploring the very
critical things you want to pursue and
being willing to then number two
eliminate the rest and number three
build a platform for effortless
execution so that doing what is
essential becomes the default position
not just the rare occasion my position
is that when people really get a chance
to think and have the space that they
can quite easily discern between the
things that are essential to them
important to them and those things that
are not the problem is not our ability
to discern it's that we don't have the
space to take the time to discern once
we have that perspective we can think
through it so my position is that we
need to develop a routine that enables
that space to think in a world where we
have so much information we need more
time to think and process it not less
and so you know one CEO that I
interviewed for the book has two hours
on his calendar every day broken up into
half-hour set
so that he has this space to stop to
turn everything off to think to see the
bigger picture I think we could all do
something similar to that the idea for
many people of saying no to a senior
leader to even family members and so on
is so unthinkable they just don't even
experiment with it so they end up being
a novice with no they just want to avoid
this like the plague but I found is that
essentialists practice and learn and
develop this skill a Kate krill is the
CEO of loft and the Ann Taylor brand and
she said that years ago she was really
bad at saying no and somebody came to
her mentor and said look you've got to
learn to to get rid of all of these
people and commitments that don't mean
anything to you because they'll rob you
of the things that really do and she
said that because she got that feedback
she did learn over the years how to say
no how to push back gracefully sensibly
but unapologetically and now she says
she's very good at it and it saved her
so many you know wasted hours wasted
days wasted commitments because she
actually learned to develop a repertoire
for saying no
one of the executives that I interviewed
for the book because he was trying to be
a good citizen to his new company ended
up saying yes to almost everything and
his stress was going up the quality of
work was going down and so he started to
you know with an experiment saying no
more often being more selective and what
he found was that the meaning of his
work was going up the value of his work
to the company was going up his stress
was going down and he ended up with one
of the best performance evaluations of
his career and one of the largest
bonuses of his career in that little
story there is the argument for
essentialism that by focusing on the few
things that are really essential we're
actually able to make a more valuable
contribution I think becoming an
essentialist is not an easy thing I
certainly think it's a revolutionary
thing you find yourself saying no when
other people are saying yes you're going
to be saying yes when other people are
saying no but in the end in the final
analysis anything less than the
disciplined pursuit of the essential
will lead to the undisciplined pursuit
of the non-essential and that's a price
I don't think many of us would
deliberately choose